the offensive line for the cleveland
browns is working long a liability when
it was joe thomas and four guys whoever
they could find to stand next to him
right
i saw stat yesterday from pro football
reference i think that baker mayfield
had more pocket time than any
quarterback in the nfl for week one well
what did he do with it that's a
different issue but they're buying him
time right they're opening holes in the
running game and that puts the focus
back on mayfield when we were working
our way through your 40 top quarterbacks
we noticed a dividing line between the
guys who can run the play that's called
and the guys who have the mobility and
the escape ability to improvise when the
play that's called goes to hell
one thing that stood out to me from
baker mayfield yeah as he's trying to
will himself to the next level he's not
one of those guys that has
enough mobility to keep a play alive
agree to come up with something once the
play that's called isn't there he tries
to yeah right maybe maybe he wants to be
like his good friend kyler murray baker
you're not kyler murray you're not
patrick mahomes you're not lamar jackson
you're closer to kirk cousins but not
quite kirk cousins but but but not even
ben roethlisberger he's not able
to to truly
make things he want you can see it in
his demeanor you can see it in the way
his body moves it's almost like he's
shocked he can't do more yeah to get
away and make something else happen but
kevin stefanski needs to get him to
color within the lines quickly he agrees
well that passing game isn't going to
take off no i i think you're right uh we
saw again some evidence there on monday
and
you know this is where i brought up too
monday too or sunday we saw evidence but
monday is where i brought up you know i
had the same concerns watching that game
and even watching back on film is just
what what is it that baker mayfield does
great that you can hang your hat on
right now i do i have a little question
there there's a lot of good
but
like the really really good quarterbacks
have some sort of an elite trait that
makes them elite in that area along with
all their other good and right now
baker's not the best decision maker he's
not the most consistent thrower within
the pocket
you know and within that he has moments
that lead to turnovers like the
interception hey year three he's
throwing a backside slam it's wide open
it's wide open he takes a three-step
drop out of the shotgun three-step game
when you're in the shotgun has to be
catch it and get ready to throw the ball
because the ball travels in the air
which makes up for the first two steps
if you were underneath center he did
that he threw it late he threw it behind
that led calais campbell have enough
time to get over there
and cause an interception but that was
all baker mayfield and his lack of
attention or detail to his feet and his
technique that way and they're just you
see that on certain throws too where you
go man the guy's open oh he missed it um
and then of course he's off page with
odell beckham jr and everything like
that so yeah a guy that like me who
likes baker mayfield i do and i like
some of the things he brings to the
table
i still am not sure what he is i don't
know yet i i don't know
i thought we knew going into last year
and last year he made us
not know even more and here we are in
week one
it didn't answer any questions so
tonight we do you know a little more
digging and hopefully we get more
evidence along those lines
and it was a thursday night in september
two years ago when the jets came to town
tyrod taylor had the start got banged up
and
baker mayfield mania was born that was
it how do you get back to that how do
you build on that how do you become
the best you can be
and is it possible that the best you
were ever going to be
is what you were two years ago it's a
depressing thought if it's even remotely
true for baker mayfield but chris we
have
a season and a week of evidence after
2018
and something's missing from the magic
that we saw right out of the gates and i
agree with you completely when you watch
baker mayfield play there's nothing that
makes you say wow there's nothing that
makes you say damn there's nothing that
makes you go on the edge of your seat
and anticipate some sort of magic it's
more like this nagging sense of what's
going to go wrong on this play oh
they're dropping back to pass what's
going to go wrong on this it is a little
you're going to be a miscommunication is
it going to be a bad route is it going
to be a mini case of alligator arms is
somebody going to get their hand in the
way what's going to happen you know they
fooled baker mayfield early on in that
game calais campbell dropped into
coverage and tipped a ball and then it
was picked off and i'm sure that was
just a product of film study about the
tendencies and the tells of baker
mayfield where maybe he doesn't look to
see if there's anyone in that spot when
he throws the ball and he just throws it
and caleus campbell was there yeah the
first interception of the game that
opened the floodgates no no doubt and
that's that's what i was saying like
there was attention to detail with the
lack of his drop you know he he he
caused that interception calais campbell
if you're the quarterback was playing
right defensive tackle he was throwing a
slant to his left side it was wide open
there was no linebackers over there or
anything
he took extra steps in his drop which
made him late throw in the ball the guy
was open before that for a second and a
half already and he threw the ball and
the ball was going to be behind the the
receiver either anyways if you watch the
replay you'll see the receivers getting
ready to turn his body as the ball is
coming in the air because he knows it's
behind him but then calais campbell gets
his hand out there and that's what we're
talking about it's just it's rough
around the edges with baker mayfield
right now you're right there's some
where you go man that's a hell of a
throw and then you're going oh i don't
know what the hell is going to happen
here whoa that was a dicey decision ah
that ball was a little off target oh i
thought he was gonna get out of the
pocket but he didn't he got sacked it's
a it is it's a lot of that so i think
when you bring up like his rookie year
the first thing that came to my mind was
a guy that got back
you know drop back aggressively made a
quick decision and let the ball go i see
hesitation and thinking in his game
right now i can think of two early
throws in this game just this past week
where
it's like
hey if you get single you just throw it
to odell beckham jr and he's got odell
beckham jr two times within the first
drive
and he like hesitates and doesn't throw
it and odell's sitting there like wait
i'm i'm open he's looking around he's
like what why didn't i get it so i i do
i get the sense looking at him that he's
still a little
all over the place mentally
flustered whatever it is uh but i would
like to see him get it on track because
yeah i i do think there's potential for
the player to be good and of course we
know they got some weapons around him
let me ask you this psychologically as a
quarterback when you are on the first
drive of the game and you throw a pass
that you believe is going to be open and
maybe pop for a nice gain and it turns
out a defensive lineman ends up right in
the spot to tip the ball away does that
make you
just like split second gunshot after
that because you were shocked by the
presence of a giant there when you
didn't expect him to be there no doubt
about it it'll make you second guess
second look from that point on because
especially when you throw an
interception that early in the game
you just go okay man i threw an
interception you know first drive of the
game it led to a touchdown for them
you know you just start to go man i i
don't want to put my team in a hole one
more mistake here we could be down 14
nothing and we haven't even like broke a
sweat yet so it will make you second
guess your throws what you're seeing you
can become extra careful which is what i
think happened to him a little bit in
the first half there i do i and i think
that even happened with some throws and
things like that to odell where he just
wasn't sure he wanted to let it go
because he was afraid he wasn't seeing
it right or whatever that is and um yeah
there's been a lot of that it's just
rough around the edges that's the way i
would say it there's good oh that's nice
but then it's oh yeah this isn't so good
and it's just never consistent and
hasn't been really ever since that
rookie year
how long's his leash do you think yeah
that's that's a good question
because
we know you and i know that kevin
stefanski has great respect for case
keenum and we've heard that from many
people in the nfl and they had a great
relationship supposedly from everything
we've heard when they were up in
minnesota
this is the number one pick but this is
a regime that didn't pick him so that
makes the lease shorter than it might
have been with the freddie kitchens or
uh the coast of course the the head
coach that drafted him who i'm blanking
on his name right now studio jackson
hugh jackson excuse me so
what do you think mike i would think
if they got to like week six seven
somewhere in there
and they're two and four
something like that i would say that's
probably around the time where they'd
finally go okay maybe we need to sit him
on the bench he needs to take a breather
sit back reevaluate himself you know the
game's just become too much i i would
imagine that what what do you what do
you think
well the bye week is always an important
spot to look at that's week nine but
when i look at the schedule for the
cleveland browns we have that graphic
and this is uh look at that that is
impressive the bengals this week if they
should lose that game although i don't
believe they will if they stick with the
running game it gets a little dicey
washington not the washington of old at
the cowboys that will not be easy the
colts who knows with them at the
steelers then another game with the
bengals and the raiders before the buy i
could see at some point if they don't
start picking up some wins if they don't
have
two wins by the second bengals game
that's when i think yeah baker
mayfield's in trouble but chris here's
the thing it's not just the relationship
between stefanski and keenum they have a
shared experience from the minneapolis
miracle that i think creates a lifetime
bond yeah and a lifetime friendship to
the extent that there wasn't already a
strong friendship between the two men
that moment
and that euphoria that was triggered
throughout the state of minnesota
throughout the organization
that creates something between
quarterback coach and quarterback that
isn't going to go away no in two years
and
if and and and it was that whole season
it was magical it was the only year that
they worked together in minnesota 2017.
so
i i think that that from the moment case
keenum was added by the browns the seed
was planted of the possibility of an
alternative to baker mayfield if he
skews toward the baker mayfield of 2019
not the baker mayfield of 2018 and i
don't think we should be surprised
if it happens and i think and look i i
don't want to go any farther than the
surface of this rabbit hole chris yeah
and i'm reluctant to even bring it up
but
conspiracy mike on a thursday morning
would say to you that baker mayfield's
about face on kneeling for the anthem
was influenced in part by the fact that
he knows he needs the fans on his side
because once they turn on him it is
going to be case kingdom time uh i agree
with that i do i think that that was a
business decision to realize like wait
i'm kind of on the fence right now here
in cleveland ohio
and let me just stand up and not be a
distraction or cause any normal noise or
have people
you know apt to jump on me a little
quicker because of this i agree
i i do agree with that i think he
assessed that situation and knew that it
would probably cause more harm than good
for himself and maybe the team
altogether i don't know maybe he just
didn't want to deal with that in the
conversation there
and i understand that i mean they're a
team that's got enough things going on
they've accomplished nothing and
you know stay the course just worry
about what you got to worry about right
now i i respect baker mayfield's stance
on a lot of this stuff i do i know he's
you know in the good fight for social
justice and everything like that um but
this is a big year for him and his
career and you're right with case keenum
and stefanski that is a special bond
they did special things that year and it
almost had a special ending the
minneapolis miracle like you said was
special uh and
i think that's like we you said that
second bangles game
if they go into pittsburgh
and lay an egg offensively and it
doesn't look good
and they're sitting there two and four
and their only wins or maybe tonight and
maybe the washington team
i think cleveland will sit down and have
serious discussions about oh what should
we do with baker mayfield is it time to
sit him down how much longer do we let
him go and i think that all will start
up
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports